once again the rain is torrential
bringing back memories about just a year
ago an avalanche of mud and rocks
thundered down this very slope
there's not much left of farmer come on
powder Julie's grandmother's house Kemal
and his son cabin are here to pay their
respects to her she was killed in her
sleep by the mudslide he came with me
and he said me Oh what happened my dad
we cannot alive in this area we go from
here we live this area it is very
dangerous but they did stay like the
other residents of the village of
symfony karma lost his fields
fortunately he also as a position as a
teacher so he can support his mother and
the rest of the family
at the foot of the mountain lies the
village of doon de co-fund
here the damage from the mudslide was
especially severe and nine people lost
their lives a country in the shadow of
the Himalayas Nepal has been hit by more
than 4000 landslides since the
devastating earthquake in April 2015 the
terrain is under stress and increasing
numbers of poorly secured roads make the
slopes even more vulnerable to erosion
the monsoon has arrived with its heavy
rains that risk of landslides increases
these school kids are constantly exposed
to danger
when a road was built here an exposed
steep mountain flank remained
for years mudslides descended on the
schoolyard it was sheer luck that no one
was hurt agronomist inoa hikari has
helped banish the threat she works for
the International Union for the
Conservation of Nature and she's relying
on Umrah so at all and fast-growing
indigenous plant also known as broom
grass it helps to keep the soil from
eroding
swell tightly and it also not only the
Holts this one it also controlled the
erosion and it also sake the watery
speed in this will appear area
the secret lies in its web like network
of roots there are very small roots like
a small field which can penetrate easily
into the soil that means and it it has
like better the the network like a root
network like this and it captured like
that all artists penetrate this wall and
it just old this while into their
network ever since a stripper vom Rizzo
was planted in the area between the road
in the schoolyard two years ago the
mudslides have stopped nowadays there so
I think we feel safe from the flood
we generally come down from beside this
road and this patter of the nails
Nepal's second largest city pokhara lies
about two hours away in the village of
san roque court is near it for years its
residents were prey to landslides they
came down this steep slope destroyed the
fields and threatened the lower part of
the village
here to Amarista was planted it's
already helped in addition a drainage
canal was built it takes up some of the
floodwater
reduces the force of the torrents and
diverts the water into the fields the
village now has more security and it
also has an additional source of income
Emery sews branched flower clusters can
be used to make brooms farmer Janu
Kabara sells them and has been able to
increase her income by 20% if I want to
earn extra money as a farmer I have to
work very hard for it but with Emery so
it's faster and what Pleasant it's quite
a good feeling about one thing
Jenica bara can use Emery so stems for
firewood and its leaves provide good
fodder for her livestock but can broom
grass also prevent major landslides
indentical font where nine people died
they've built walls at the foot of the
slope they're meant to break the force
of mud and rock slides before they reach
the village
uh no Adhikari and the villagers are not
looking for a solution for the middle
area of the slope the damage is still
visible here trees have to be planted
and the banks of the river secured to
control the landslide there is no any
magic formula yeah that means that we
are not a hundred percent sure to
control the landslide if we plant the
armed resource it will look cold soil
compactly or strongly that means it can
resist the little bit high power of
flood higher up on the slope the
villagers are now planting Emry so the
plant even grows in the eroded soil of
the landslide area effectively anchoring
it when soil is go down and landslides
we cannot survive the we cannot stay in
bliss so am I so protect the soil yeah
and then all the member of the family
can sleep
once again torrents are rushing down the
mountain Arisa won't offer protection
for another year or two the hope remains
that the disaster of 2015 won't be
repeated
you